but we try to look at the whole universe
itself
many people ask the question well
professor how do you know how do you
know that the universe is expanding how
do you know that it came from a Big Bang
can you project so far into the future
billions to trillions of years into the
future well one way we do this is by
looking at the Doppler shift
now the Doppler shift is something that
even children are familiar with when
children play star wars with each other
they go on with their rocket ships right
well what makes that year sound it's the
Doppler effect when a car moves toward
you the pitch is higher when the car
moves away from you the pitch is lower
and it sounds like this yeah we've all
heard it
same thing with starlight when yellow
light moves toward you it turns greenish
and blueish when yellow light moves away
from you it turns reddish now how can
you memorize this well I was reading
paper a few years ago and I read this
fascinating story of a high school
physics teacher who got a speeding
ticket for running a red light
the physics teacher went to the
blackboard and said your honor my car
was moving toward yellow light light is
compressed in the forward direction when
he moved toward it and therefore it
turned green this is the Doppler shift
he said and he went to the blackboard
and he correctly wrote down all the
equations of the Doppler shift and then
this high school physics teacher said
your honor I do not deserve a traffic
ticket well the judge scratched his head
and according to the article the judge
said well I guess there is a law higher
than the laws of the state of New Jersey
and these are the laws of physics but
then according to the article there was
a high school kid in the courtroom and
he raised his hand and he said your
honor I'm just a high school kid but I
happened to be in his high school
physics class and he just taught weeks
ago that this only happens when you
approach the speed of light
end of article 2 this day I still don't
know what happened to that poor high
school kid but I tell my students
then if I'm ever in court arguing a
speeding ticket for red light they
better not raise their hand if they know
it's good for them and they know what's
good for their grade so when we look in
the heavens we look at star light
emitted from distant galaxies and we
find that the light is slightly reddish
redder than it's supposed to be that
means that these objects these gigantic
galaxies are moving away from us and
therefore the universe is expanding well
we can run the videotape backwards and
by running the videotape backwards we
can then calculate when all these
galaxies came from a single point and
that's how we calculate the age of the
universe by simply hitting the rewind
button when we calculate the expansion
of the universe oh by running the video
tape backwards we see that the universe
is about 13.7 billion years old plus or
minus 1% so we now know the age of the
universe 13.7 billion years by running
the video tape backwards but what
happens if we hit fast-forward what
happens if we go forward in time
billions of years well here it gets
murkier but by analyzing how the burst
has been expanding in the past we used
to think that the universe is slowing
down we used to think the universe is
ageing and therefore it's slowing down
running out of steam wrong we now
believe that the universe is speeding up
it's actually accelerating isn't the way
mode which means that instead of dying
in a Big Crunch will probably die in a
big freeze we're not positive we don't
know if this will keep on billions of
years but if so the universe is in a
runaway mode it means that one day
perhaps when we look at the night sky
perhaps we'll see almost nothing because
the distant galaxies are so far that
light cannot even reach our telescopes
not a pleasant thought but our universe
may eventually die in a big freeze
rather than a Big Crunch
nobody knows when this big freeze will
take place or if it will ever take place
however estimates have been made perhaps
hundreds of billions of years perhaps
trillions of years one day it will get
so cold that you look at the night sky
and it'll be almost totally black all
the stars will have exhausted all their
nuclear fuel the universe will consist
of neutron stars dead black holes the
temperature will reach near absolute
zero and at that point even
consciousness even thought itself cannot
exist and some people think that perhaps
the laws of physics are a death warrant
to all intelligent life that we're all
going to die when the universe space is
over but you know there's a loophole
there's a loophole in the laws of
physics
you see trillions of years from now
perhaps intelligent life will be able to
master what is call the Planck energy
the Planck energy is the ultimate energy
it's the energy of the Big Bang it's the
energy at which gravity itself begins to
break down you know that if you have a
microwave oven and you heat it up you
can take ordinary water and make it boil
ice can melt water can boil but what
happens if you crank up that microwave
often even more eventually the steam
starts to break up into oxygen and
hydrogen if you crank it up some more
all of a sudden ions form atoms
themselves begin to rip apart and then
if you crank up that microwave oven even
more then even the nucleus begins to
break apart and you get a plasma of
protons and neutrons you crank it up
some more
any glue on plasma and if you crank it
up some more to this incredible energy
10 to the 19 billion electron volts
we're not sure but perhaps even space
itself begins to boil even space-time
becomes unstable bubbles begin to form
at this Planck energy and perhaps these
gateways gateways to a parallel universe
no of course we're not this this is
sheer speculation but there are theories
which say that there could be universes
right next to our universe and in fact
the Large Hadron Collider will give us
the first experimental evidence about
the existence of parallel universes so
think of us as ants living on a sheet of
paper but perhaps there are other
parallel sheets of paper with other ants
living on them and perhaps we are very
close to these other universes but we
can't reach them the energy necessary to
reach a parallel universe would be the
Planck energy 10 to the 19 billion
electron volts I would suppose that
trillions of years from now intelligent
life facing the ultimate demise of the
universe itself
might decide to leave the universe to
leave our universe and enter a parallel
universe in the same way that Alice
entered the looking-glass to enter
Wonderland
you